Kings have the Kopitar Byfield kempe line
out now as gabov feeds Byfield moving to
his left at the Circle a shot kicked out
rebound Kopitar save made against Vegas
and against San Jose they were down
one- nothing after the first period
here's a turnover lafier swings
it in front cev Dall stopped by
but he'll be able to come across watch him get
the glove right on top of the pad right there
wide open that's the way golender doing a very
very good job Kia for Spence with a shot blocker
save in the air it winds up in the corner still
in play held in by the Kings power play winding
down here is Spence across left Circle Z know
across right Circle shot save is made in the bid
by C well that last shot the passes are exactly
the way you want them so they've had to dump it
and in case as the king's defense have get back
quicker on the retrieval dowy following up his
own shot right there Jim noticed from the Oilers
they're also dropping back into kind of a one31
neutral zone something they probably did not do
a lot of under Jay Woodcraft maybe a little bit
of a change here McDavid checked as he got to the
Kings line by field the other way will throw it in
behind the goal forcing the goal Skinner to play
it and away with it Nick David ahead for Newen
Hopkins his shot from the Blue Line kicked out and
that'll be a shot on goal there first for Roy and
to Kee on the right side sends it across the ice
on the left wing boards kobitar up high in the
middle Roy to Kee a shot save loose Puck cleared
five on five mentality dump the puck in works even
when you have the man advant Kee out now led the
team with 11 Power Play Goals last season takes
it wide beats the middle shot score Kevin palala
with a rocket and it's a power play goal to give
the Kings a one nothing lead and Fala for one
timers on power PL entry perfect watch this no
hesitation whatsoever and that shot comes from a
pretty good area give fala credit though it's a
onetime shot he's going into the puck and look at
the place bar down it took him a while to get the
puck in the zone buard worked over by grundstrom
they battle again grundstrom with it threw it in
front shot save has made rebound backhander
blocked oh Lewis with two great chances what
the right decision he realizes he's too close to
the goal tender so he doesn't have room to elevate
maybe that was the best chance right here on the
back end you see him kind of take it back hold
hold and they get it on left wing where it's sved
in Deep by the Oilers and and McLoud Kopitar ahead
speed space Kee in shoots scores upstairs for the
juice Adrien Kee and the kings are up two nothing
that gets things going now watch this receive
turn and shot mentality near post far Corner head
up kick it in near far there it is two nothing
but again it started right down in the king Zone
where they were willing to get back Oilers power
play no goals in the last five games Newen Hopkins
for McDavid shot hit the post tried the short side
on ta but did maybe Ser more so than most teams so
McDavid looking for an opportunity and you can see
he had the Trevor Moore spot right there but it's
off the crossbar Anders yesterday only practiced
one unit on the power play and they stick stay
out for most of the 2 minutes on most power plays
anyway looks like they're going to do that here
down low it comes McDavid a shot and he scores
this time he put it over the right shoulder of
talit the referee pointed McDavid knew it was in
it's a power play goal yeah we'll see if the kings
make the adjustment now on the next kill players
that can do it middle to the outside that's the
normal up we saw this earlier even though he's
at a bad angle he just hoist it and he banks it
off the golender head it's to the point where you
know we're seeing this more and more and more now
we'll see here Nick what happens when the Kings
do get an opportunity do get time with the puck
that's a big difference right now they going
to work hard to check eoma Drive save has made
rebound bouncing away with it the veteran Lewis
as far as getting in and deep to concentrate on
McDavid again change of Direction you can see
threw everyone there talet found a way now on
the left wing boards gabov for Lewis back to gabov
a shot blocked loose in front shot save is made
off lazat while lazat was falling and now here
is McDavid speeding through Center ice dropping
for nurse nurse in shoots save is made no rebound
and a whistle available right away so we'll keep
our eye on not whether he gets back to the bench
nee with a goal and assist in that first period
in 8 seconds ERS have a power play McDavid with
it to the net Center a cross score dral and now
they will still have the power play in 5 seconds
the spin by McDavid we talked about slot passes
you'll see a stumble by gabov he tries to go out
and he gets at least he forces McDavid down low
but then you're hoping for coverage in front and
try to take away the potential receiver of that
pass so we've seen Kings making changes brunstrom
kicks it free for Moore just on Moore out to Deno
cross ice Dy one timer and a save offside is
called I know that dry CID will scored on a
one time shot I think both goenda and Skinner have
done a good job in these situations tonight where
you've got to go post to post Ryan centering
pass block Kings don't clear held in brown
shoots save made rebound off a stick and into
the corner Newen Hopkins got it to Heyman now
Heyman hands it off here is McDavid and on
goal a chance a rebound hit the side of the
net another chance in tight a favorable line
change for the Kings I think the Kings have
an advantage here with the Personnel they have
on the ice dubba in with fiala dubba to fiala
hit a leg almost went in hit an Oiler leg dubba
for fiala up top dubba to the left Circle dubba
moving down low four of nine in his career
as he just saw a left shot more in shoots and
scores a lot of times he goes top glove
right that was actually a little bit
higher than normal yeah it looks like
Skinner was cheating for the glove and
he threw him off by going against the
grein jimmmy well there's where that
scouting Conor McDavid in round one in
out an angle McDavid in on gold dicks and
scores to see if the golender
is going to do something you
see how he opens up closes the Ryan newon
Hopkins in on talin daks and scores let's see how
slow he goes here for shooting room head up turn
now slow it down just slow slow slow and look
by the time the shot there's a little bit of a
deep there if he scores the Oilers win the game
Leon dry Sidle a left shot in save is made his
former teammate making the save and we'll see
again depth here the dve Shettles going back
but see look at C the veteran Andre Kopitar
his third attempt this season in shoots glove
save out there you'll see it from behind copar big
glove wide open cop's trying to get a little bit
higher veteran Derek Ryan in round four speeding
in on telet shoots and scores and the Oilers win
the shootout and this the first meeting between
these division Rivals this season 3-2 is the final